these scaly red patches are the
hallmarks of a common condition called
psoriasis it's a disease involving
immune cells this was discovered by
chance when in the late 1970s scientists
noticed that the immunosuppressive drugs
cyclosporine can improve the condition
skin has three major tissue segments the
epidermis is composed largely of
specialized cells called keratinocytes
these originate from a single layer of
basal keratinocytes which divide
continuously and give rise to cells that
migrate towards the skin's surface
during this process they progressively
differentiates into cornea sites which
form a protective barrier below the
epidermis is the dermis here cells
called fibroblasts secrete fibers that
form a dense extracellular matrix this
layer also contains hair follicles sweat
glands sebaceous glands and blood
capillaries as well as lymphatic vessels
these are a major conduit for immune
cells such as macrophages dendritic
cells and T cells dendritic cells can
capture foreign antigen and present it
to T cells T cells are immune effector
cells they can broadly be divided into
cytotoxic T cells which directly kill
infected cells and T helper cells that
play a key role in orchestrating overall
immune responses in many ways the immune
pathways that become activated in
psoriasis are amplifications of the
immune activity of normal skin however
the trigger for this inflammatory
disease is unknown current models
proposed that dendritic cells sense
stressed keratinocytes and invading
microorganisms and start to respond by
producing signaling molecules known as
cytokines these activate T cells and
other immune cells which in turn produce
their own cytokines those signals
stimulate keratinocytes to proliferate
and to secrete further mediators and
create a vicious cycle of inflammatory
responses
overall this results in an accumulation
of immune cells and the formation of a
thickened inflamed epidermis several
biologic drugs have been developed to
target inflammatory mediators in
psoriasis the most widely used agents
for severe psoriasis dampened down
cytokine TNF alpha but that treatment
doesn't work for everyone up to a third
of patients ultimately do not respond
however in the past decade insights into
T cell biology have uncovered some
promising new drug targets traditionally
T helper cells have been classified into
two subsets T helper 1 cells which are
pro-inflammatory and T helper 2 cells
which are anti-inflammatory however the
picture has become much more complicated
with the identification of many other
subsets which subset a T helper cell
will belong to depends on the cytokines
it encounters when it first interacts
with a dendritic cell each subset can
then be told apart because they secrete
characteristic cytokines in the context
of psoriasis and inflammation T helper
17 cells have attracted particular
attention they're part of a group known
as type 17 cells because they produce
the cytokine il-17 this cytokine can
promote chronic inflammation and tissue
destruction in psoriasis dendritic cells
produced two important cytokines il-12
and il-23 il-12 induces the
differentiation of T helper 1 cells
which produce the cytokines interferon
gamma and TNF alpha il-23 in turn
induces T helper 17 cells which make
il-17 and other pro-inflammatory
cytokines
scientists are now developing a number
of biologic drugs that are targeted at
il-17 and other elements of the il-17
signaling cascade interesting targets
include il-23 a shared subunit of both
il-12
and il-23 the different isoforms of
il-17 and the il-17 receptor as well as
a protein that's required for the
production il-17 as il-17 functions
mainly locally in the skin and in
mucosal tissues such agents may have
fewer side-effects and current drugs
which acts systemically and they might
be effective in patients who don't
respond to therapies that target TNF
alpha the first of these agents has
already been approved for psoriasis and
others have shown promising results in
clinical trials many of these are also
in development for other inflammatory
diseases including rheumatoid arthritis
asthma and colitis making the il-17
cascade one of the hottest targets for
inflammatory diseases
you